er ist nicht out of the box wie wir da
gelernt haben als er ist noch nicht auf
dem weg scheint über den berg dann im
sprachgebrauch amerikanischer ärzte zu
heißen
also was ja vollkommen klar ist oder was
zumindest bisher nicht gesagt wird aber
wie vielten tag dieser infektion donald
trump sich befindet und es gibt so
gewisse tage die angeblich besonders
riskant sein sollen es besteht also
durchaus die möglichkeit dass noch was
passiert ja wir erinnern uns an boris
johnson der hat auch gesagt alles gut
alles fein er bleibt jetzt bisserl zu
hause und auf einmal war auf der
intensivstation und das innerhalb
kürzester zeit corona so unberechenbar
und der eindruck das muss man natürlich
klar sagen den donald trump da
vermittelt dass man corona mit
willenskraft der oder weil man so ein
toller typ ist wie donald haben einfach
schlagen kann ist natürlich totaler
quatsch
natürlich kann corona donald trump
innerhalb von zwei tagen zeigen was
corona bedeutet nämlich am
beatmungsgerät zu hängen das ist dass es
immer noch nichts was man ausschließen
kann allerdings ist er natürlich umgeben
von ärzten das haben wir auch in den
letzten tagen gehört immer wieder die
ihm auch experimentelle experimentelle
therapien und medikamente geben ja
sozusagen im moment nicht nur
commander-in-chief sondern auch
versuchskaninchen in chief der wird
offenbar im moment alles ausprobiert an
ihm was es so an corona medikamenten
gibt das scheint bisher ganz gut zu
wirken auch wenn er bisher kurzatmig
erschienen bei seinem auftritt auf der
treppe aber natürlich kann sich das
innerhalb von wenigen stunden drehen und
das muss man sagen marin ran der
hubschrauber der legendäre hubschrauber
wieder abheben in richtung volturi
zurück ins krankenhaus das wäre dann bei
der inszenierung die den moment
abliefert der öffentlichkeit nur noch
sehr schwer als strahlenden erfolg zu
erklären
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren